that's Cristiano Ronaldo he's the best
soccer player in the world I'm in Madrid
because Nike wants me to see his new
shoes this isn't just a step forward in
good design this is a giant leap Phil
McCartney is VP of footwear for Nike the
new Superfly is the latest addition to
the story
mercurial silo a silo is an industry
term it's basically a line of shoes I am
curious about what Nike calls the silo
approach this is a specifically for one
type of player the modern game is really
defined by four playing styles and those
playing styles or how we orientate our
product time so think of the player like
Cristiano Ronaldo his game is about
explosive speed so we create a product
based on the insight for him and players
who have that style at the World Cup
this summer Cristiano Ronaldo will be
wearing the mercurial superfly a line of
cleats is an expensive investment and
any single player can blow out a knee or
have a bad year so in soccer Nike and
Adidas don't make a product around an
athlete they make a silo then they move
an athlete into it when it gets old or
injured there's a new player waiting who
can step into the same silo even Nike
admits that will probably never be Air
Jordans for soccer is it possible for
something to happen around a Ronaldo
soccer cleat the way the Air Jordan
became something greater than a shoe or
do you think that's not going to happen
again
I think there's in football azores
movements I think the game is defined by
key moments and I think when we can link
product innovation to key athletes to
key moments that's when the magic
happens what it means there is no
just like nike adidas has four cleat
silos but it started earlier in 1994
with the predator a cleat with grips
over the toes that made it easier to
bend the ball then Anita's got his
predators on a kid named David Beckham
in 2004 adidas launched a limited run of
his predator silo in David Beckham
colors the runs sold out at 723 euros a
pair today adidas has Lionel Messi the
other guy who's the best player in the
world Messi has his own logo but he
doesn't have his own shoe Messi where's
the f50 a little kid you want to be the
next is he Don the next pack on the next
Messi how do you do that well I want the
shoe they want to buy I want to be that
player this is Jakob my best friend's
son at soccer practice in Germany Messi
the stadia schewe taitea adidas or Aniki
I ask the kids whether Lionel Messi
wears adidas or Nike unveil up adidas
hey half the kids think that Messi
where's adidas half the kids think that
Messi where is Nike that's a god he does
it doesn't really matter that these kids
don't know which shoes Lionel Messi
wears at this age their parents buy
their cleats when they're 15 and have
their own money silos and player style
will start to matter until then it's
enough that adidas makes sure they know
who Lionel Messi is